[Music]
woven from manila sisal or flax fibers
traditional ropes are a binding element
in our world the process starts with
racks of natural fiber yarns the yarns
are funneled through separators which
configure them to twist evenly together
the fibers then travel through tubes
that squeeze them into bundles workers
tie the ends of the bundles onto a
wheeled vehicle called the forming
machine they roll the machine back until
there's no slack in the bundles the
machine is then sent to the opposite end
of the factory over 1,000 feet away as
the machine travels backwards its gears
turn hooks twisting the yarns into a
tight configuration the formation of the
twists ensure an even distribution of
tension this is what makes roads so
strong this long indoor space is called
a rope walk there aren't many of them
left in the world
when the machine reaches the back wall
it stops and workers cut both ends of
the strands they tie them to post to
maintain tension and prevent unraveling
on one side they tie three of the
strands to a machine that will transform
them into a rope halfway down
they bring in a cart that holds a piece
of grooved wood known as a top they tuck
the twisted strands into the grooves of
the top they then roll the cart down to
face the rope making machine
a worker ties rope around the strands on
the top this holds them in place as the
rope making machine twists the three
strands into one the Rope machine with
twisting hooks remains in the same place
when the cart arrives at the opposite
side of the building the rope is formed
a worker removes the ties around the top
they now have a piece of rope that's
over 700 feet long and almost 5 inches
in diameter